I'm the biggest advocate for freedom of  speech and what it means to be an  advocate for freedom of speech is speech  that even offends you it's okay you're  allowed to offend me that's what it  means the most concerning part is when  financial services start to get involved  and start de-platforming people Vining  people for saying supposedly the  incorrect thing Kanye West for example  is now no longer allowed to bank with JP  Morgan PayPal of finding people for  covert misinformation what does that  even mean every week what is defined as  misinformation is constantly changing so  it's absolutely absurd to start shutting  people out of society